I'm not a trump fan yeah I'm not going
to reverse course all of us but what I'm
saying to you is that is a position
though you know who you're not voting
vote for Trump he would not I'm not a
trump fan wow that's that what would it
take for you to vote for Biden what
would it take ones how about this listen
how about this hear me out we're at a
place when's the last time you voted for
a Democrat Clinton okay so it's been 30
years now and I saw this the other day
and it's I think it's absolutely
essential to to where we are and I think
it's going forward we're at a point of
no return and I say that because you
when I was growing up and I was not very
political when I was growing up but yet
people left to center right of Center
and then you had Center and all the
things the Democrats Republicans of our
childhood are gone
but we're at a point in time where
there's no going back and there is no
peace because both sides
see each other as inherently evil right
and I tend to believe as a patriotic
flag waving American uh and all the and
again I've known president Trump since
2006. all the things you can say about
him you can say about them but the fact
of the matter this country in every
metric possible was better under his
presidency except for the fact that the
left was angry bitter and hateful the
economy minority employment uh female
employment the stock every by every
measurable metric that we measure that
we have in the past measured Presidents
by we were better
and by every those same metrics in the
last two were far far worse and and the
fact that we're having a conversation
around who you would vote for that blows
me away that blows me away to think that
an educated person would ever consider
allowing Democrats to be in power again
for the rest of our lives as long as
people live I've watched I mean we've
all watched it for two years
that this the destruction there that
they've wrought on the foundational
principles of this country and listen
you can say oh you want this Foundry
this country was found on judeo
Christian principles it just was you
don't have to agree with it you can you
can want it to go in a different way but
that's the way it is
and the fact that we're having these
discussions now about
who who I've been alive for two I've
watched it for two years I've seen it
happen for two years I've seen the moral
Decay listen I grew up at my dinner
table right when I did something wrong
I'd slap on the back of that I grew up
at a dinner table and and the but the
farther from the dinner table in the
Bible this country's gotten the farther
down the toilet it's gotten and it's
just been sad to watch how do we get
here in your opinion how do we get here
apathy
for gosh 30 or 40 years we had 40 50
voter turnout
we we let them get where they are and I
think there's a certain level of
corruption in the process that has
gotten people in to office because you
can't convince me that a majority of
people in Maxine Waters District or
aoc's District or Nancy Vote or Eric
Schiff these people are are the dumbest
of the dumb there's there's just
there I mean listen we we know that
there is a massive amount of election
fraud in the last election how much I
don't know that we'll ever find out but
we know because we've seen the evidence
and and you know I was up at three in
the morning when the vote total for
Biden Changed by 2 million and trumps
didn't move an inch and I was like wait
a minute what just happened
but you know you say something like that
now
and you're you're a conspiracy theorist
I God my God I don't know how many years
ago I mentioned something I I didn't
know what Q was
and I somehow somebody sent me a Twitter
link or something and I and I wrote down
you know this is actually kind of
answering I want to follow this and find
out what it is so I became a cute
disciple from that point on it doesn't
matter what I've ever said or what I
actually said but what do you mean you
you someone labeled you I've been I've
been a q Anon person since then and my I
like everything else my mom taught me
how to speed read when I was young I I
have 15 or 20 books sitting by my bets I
read everything about everything that I
can find out yeah and I like to find out
about stuff and so I was curious about
it
and I come to find out that everything
they've ever said was going to happen
never happened and and it's it's pretty
much a group of people that are all
bought in on on conspiracy stuff that
isn't happening and hasn't happened and
none of it's ever come to fruition so
you're calling out Q right now but but
no but my point is those those niches
exist everywhere in every sort of
conspiracy theory and and but but here's
the thing they're not all conspiracies
the key the trouble is finding out
figure out which ones are right are real
and are not and and you know it's I
think in a lot of ways if you the
internet
proven to be incredibly valuable and
unbelievably dangerous at the same time
because of
you know the I don't want to say power
but you know being able to find out and
look and research and understand the
world going on around you in a much
larger way now than we ever could
um that's where I get back to how could
anybody
if Trump runs against whoever next
election how can anybody not vote for it
any logical adult rational educated
person not
not a good public speaker not a funny
guy by any Street nothing worse than a
funny someone who's not funny that
thinks they are
but he delivered on literally every
campaign promise he made
and you you cannot like him he's easy
not to like I like him I've again I've
known him for for a while and and I know
the personal side I know the guy's got a
heart
an enormous heart and that's my phone
again sorry about that but the fact of
the matter is you know where we're at
now after two years of this but I think
there's such a yearning in this country
for something new something fresh we've
seen the trumpets we've seen the Trump
show but hold on a second we've also
seen the Bible show neither of them are
what the country wants well but again
Max Capacity but we asked for it
remember what the big cry was during the
Trump run up to the election we want
someone who isn't the establishment we
want someone who isn't a politician
that's what it looks like an outsider to
drain the swamp that's what it looks
like it's again that's what the right
one is no everybody the left wanted to
tell the ref left
this is what it looks like when a guy
who isn't bought by anybody isn't owned
by anybody and is a business Problem
Solver does he have you know I love the
people call him you know he's filed for
bankruptcy guys had over 500 business
transactions he's filed for bankruptcy
12 times I'll take that batting average
I mean it but the hatred is so deep and
so deranged that it makes people I think
do illogical things do you think that
that hatred
obviously coming from the left and a lot
of it's some from the traditional Rhino
Republicans as well yeah right I mean
that that exists right do you think
that's going anywhere anytime soon no oh
God no all right no it's just growing
right no it it yeah so so am I so my
question is are you ready to double down
on that knowing or is it time to maybe
anoint a new candidate there was like a
scientist there would be nobody to be
anointed because the game is foment the
anger against the opponent right so it
doesn't matter whether it's Trump or
this person or Biden or this person
you're going to see this massive game
unfold to foment as much controversy and
anger in the other side that is the
reality of our elections by the way Tom
you're not wrong you're absolutely right
but amplify that times 10 when Trump's
name is in the middle
maybe maybe in one neighborhood but in
the other neighborhood amplify it times
10 when Biden's name is that's my point
but but nobody's got one-sided nobody
gets more hate than Trump nobody nothing
close not even close nope Obama
we are at a point where both sides see
the other side as inherently evil and
there's no middle ground anymore right
and that's dangerous because there's
nobody out there that's looking to put
that bridge over troubled water and do
you think Trump's gonna be that guy no
no so the country will be again it'll go
in my opinion the Trump the the things
that people Matt that matter like your
income the price of gas your 401k all
the things that matter to Everyday
Americans gets better
otherwise it doesn't so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]